um so because women in the west are
having a harder and harder time with
submission
should Western men just go to foreign
countries for women I'm becoming
convinced so I'm going to give my take
on this first I think personally a
couple things if you can afford to the
average man makes forty five thousand
dollars per year I don't know if a
cross-continental
move is really an option for most guys
but if you can afford to and you can go
find a submissive feminine woman outside
of the West I'd tell you to go do it
um but the only issue we're gonna have
is the internet is is everywhere so I
think the Western mindset is kind of
seeping to all other parts of the world
so it's going to become tougher and
tougher but I think if you can afford it
go do it well I would I would I get you
but as a woman who's been raised by
Foreign you know individuals who didn't
grow up here I can say that there's the
problem is people do not see the point
in everybody having a set purpose
everyone wants to do everything and it
doesn't work like that as a woman in a
family if you are a wife you do your
wife duties I've I was raised like that
I understand the benefits of my
grandfather having my grandmother by his
by his side my dad had been my mom by
his side right but you can't be
traditional though because because like
I'm saying over a certain age like you
really can't be say you're traditional
because like I really feel like that's
like an under 25 and under type thing
like if you're really traditional you
get married before the age of 25.
okay I'll get you but it's
contextualizing it into the current day
so for me as a woman
you know being in a relationship I have
to have my part to play but I have to
accept that the the man is the leader
and if you have a problem with having a
leader uh per you know giving a man
responsibility of that nature to make
decisions then you're you're sure but so
I'm saying I'm saying typically like you
can go to other countries and find
younger women that want to be wives yeah
and and they're younger than us right
they're more traditional than us I'm
saying if you could afford it why
wouldn't you tell a guy to do it yeah I
think most guys can't afford it and I
think the Western mindset is seeping
everywhere it would depend where you go
to find a wife depends on your culture
as well some cultures you've got a place
where you can go you've got an Islamic
background or a culture you might be
able to go to your ancestral Homeland or
even into Africa and so forth I really
do and across the Middle East well it's
very different and to be honest I would
tell them and you can find a traditional
woman in the UK and across Europe you
really can because even London itself is
so diverse there's millions of people
from all different types of culture and
some may a dear to their culture quiet
severely and they might follow those
those traditional rules but if you got
the money and you want to travel and
have that experience you might have a
higher percentage of finding that woman
especially out of big major cities like
if you live outside of London you might
find it hard like to find a decent woman
from a different sort of culture than a
traditional Western culture but yeah I
want to tell a man not to and if he has
the sort of the Moolah the money to go
and do that and bring someone back home
because more than likely you're not
going to go and live in a third world
country you're going to bring them back
here that's that's what I would question
like the logistics of it because how
well could you really get to know her on
like trips so so to me the the logistics
would be kind of hard to iron out
because you want to vet a girl before
you marry him yeah and so but then you'd
have to pay for her to come here and
then vet her that way and so that's like
a pretty it's a big one where would she
stay probably with you oh that's a
pretty big you can't guarantee that
after you bring her here she might not
adopt Western that's what she's saying
the internet's everywhere yeah it's like
Instagram's everywhere so a pretty girl
in a small village in the middle of
nowhere can still get flown out by a
rapper or an NBA player yeah I think
there's a lot of variables that you do
have to consider like before I said you
know it depends where you're getting
going to get you know a wife from
because you could go to a country and
yet they're more traditional in nature
and they're much easier to deal with or
you can go to another particular country
and they actually just in a position
where they are so in their culture they
actually believe they have to be in a
box and the reason why that might
present an issue for me the reason why I
would say
you know if you want to go and get a
wife from abroad fair enough but why
don't you get a wife here's the world
and get somebody who is effectively a
robot well Western women are more
argumentative that's what it is and so
yeah so that's what you get with that
the critical thinking like most most
guys aren't don't really care like it's
just not they don't really care but I'm
saying it kind of depends what you're
looking for it's not something I would
advise and be like go here and find a
wife I would be like oh yeah you could
go to some place I mean what would I
know but I would There Are Places I
might recommend and this places I
absolutely would not recommend and then
there's places where I'm like but over
here you can have the value of things
like as I said you know critical
thinking that kind of
open-mindedness if you get what I mean
versus finding someone who's innately
rigid because their society was rigid if
you get what I'm saying yeah I think
those guys typically like the girls that
are a bit more original they're
traditional yeah
what does it say it says that she's a
quality wife to be honest because
because a quality wife is a help mate no
a quality a quality wife has a is a
virgin actually if we're gonna if we're
going to be 100 but that's almost like
I'm saying I want somebody who's not too
bright do you see what I'm saying no
it's not no not necessarily maybe it's
okay it's the the president's right-hand
man
is are they not bright no they're just
good at making the president look good I
guess so and so that's that's like what
a wife's duty is it's to make your man
look good I mean perhaps I mean you
could say it Empower your man yeah but
I'm not necessarily talking about you
know oh they're not capable I'm kind of
saying what kind of person and mindset
are you trying to get because there's
certain parts where you can go you can
get someone who's more traditional and
that's just more to do with their
environment and it's innate to them and
you can go to certain parts where
it might not even be let's say a choice
to be traditional if you get what I'm
saying it might be some culture yeah
yeah yeah and and I would argue it
really really really does depend on what
you're trying to what you're trying to
find well if a wife and mother yes so so
for a wife or mother with with I would
say a healthy mindset that that you
don't think that's a healthy mindset to
be a helper all cultures have a healthy
mindset I wore a hundred you can't
disrespect people's culture like that
don't say because you come from this
culture you don't have a healthy mindset
you can't really say that no you're
completely right but I will 100 say one
of the things that I completely and
utterly
um prize over anything
is the Liberty to be able to have a
choice to experience do you see what I'm
saying and it really depends on what
you're trying to find are you trying to
observe tradition though no not all not
all not all not all um and I will say
this and I don't care I mean not all
Traditions are fair and not all cultures
are equal
right but you're assuming you know
better than the people that have put
those positions
not all Traditions are fair or equal
well one men and women are different so
we're never going to be equal into it
absolutely but you don't you don't know
why those Traditions are there so
something that may look silly to you
from the outside looking and there's a
good reason for it and they did it for
hundreds no but that's why I'm saying
you might go somewhere else and you
might not go another place or you might
just stay here where we have of the
mindset where you're allowed to have
things like critics where they're
feminists and well I'm struggling that's
why the man's asking the question should
I go abroad feminists are not I mean we
all know what happened now I said it
before like yeah it has become a little
bit tyrannical pretty much because we're
in a society that facilitates their
their Vengeance mindset rather than
doing things which is actually
correct healthy stable makes sense do
you see what I'm saying we live in an
age where we're just like oh no we have
to make sure we don't offend and we have
to be correct and we have to be right
all the time and they didn't have a stop
line yeah they just kept on going to the
point where it actually became
detrimental well that's one of the
things and feminism has always been a
terrorist movement they were they were
even in that because it started in sent
oh my God I can't say the name but in
New York send Tikka something okay don't
roast me in the chat Falls in New York
and and it was it was mostly men that
started it actually it was it and back
then they were planning assassinations
and bombings so they were they were like
they would compare them to antifa which
makes sense yeah yeah so I mean they've
always been a hate group yeah but I mean
I mean the point I'm trying to make is
there wasn't a stop line do you see what
I'm saying to the so it's kind of kind
of gone back on itself the freedoms are
actually taken away from our freedoms
and they're actually affecting the waste
Society T is is but so why would a guy
deal with that mindset if he doesn't
have to now I'm saying the only reason
why is because even with all these flaws
because I was I would use this I'll say
this before I move on to my final Point
like part of the thing about
establishing a society with freedom is
that our freedoms are only relatively
recent relatively recent and think about
it 100 years 100 years that's still
relatively recent in the grand scheme of
things like do you know what I mean six
of my lives I mean Perhaps Perhaps but
that's also something to do with me
today no it's true but that's also a
society on learning hundreds of years of
a particular practice but just a century
it's not unlearning when when remember
men had to fight in Wars so you could
argue that you could argue that they
were the oppressed sex I mean you could
argue the point I'm trying to make is
that
with the introduction of Rights and it
being a much more recent thing say for
example women's freedoms on feminism
that's that's an example we're in a
we're at a stage where
we're learning to walk before we run so
there's always going to be times when
you fall over there's going to be times
when you bust your knee there's going to
be times when you hurt yourself there's
going to be times when you get it wrong
what do you mean when we're learning to
walk for what I mean when if if we're
going to introduce things like freedoms
and you know women's rights and stuff
the journey to the place which makes
sense is going to be full of a lot of
hurdles and a lot of people doing
nonsense before we get to a place where
it makes sense do you see what I'm
saying no because I feel like we've been
running no I feel like I have I think I
mean birth control was developed in the
60s oh no absolutely so so we've had
reproductive power much more
reproductive okay let me use this as a
name we've had that without being too in
fact okay
think of it as
look at feminism okay yeah now I might
be going a little bit off tangent but
and maybe I might be making connecting
dots that aren't necessarily correct but
now look at things like transgenderism
okay do you see what I'm saying when
it's kind of growing a bit out there
feminism with transgenderism no I mean I
mean think of it like this and I don't
know if I'm explaining it correctly I'm
maybe I'm just overthinking this but you
get what I'm saying right
I'm not too sure where the two are tying
up you kind of get what I'm saying right
no no no
okay we'll basically put it like this
let's see
all the all the types of freedoms and
rights are you saying they've gone too
far basically is what you're saying yeah
but I mean let's
um let's say it's now we've now reached
a stage where we're even watering down
the concept of a woman
do you see what I'm saying and now it's
it's kind of
gone so far that it's actually
contradictory to what feminism is now
you've got thing right um
you've been advocating for that other
than the other cultures that exist like
without these sort of factors
saying that they are not open-minded
remember that you're suffering from
these consequences
we've been running I don't believe we've
been running in Africa they've been
running they've had kings and queens and
women Norma langa you've had Amina
you've had Cleopatra you've had Azure of
the Islamic
because they because the whole world has
women have been taking their place over
time it's only in the west where they've
been potentially restricted and now
that's been implemented and changed
throughout other cultures they've been
fully established as Leaders as like
Warriors as queens and that's not just
in Africa it's foreign
because like we just had our roles like
even when we didn't have the right to
vote we couldn't get drafted yeah I
would I mean I would argue I would argue
I would argue that like honestly I don't
know what we were fighting for now I
don't know what we were fighting for
after we got the right to vote and most
women didn't even want that I mean
perhaps but I mean that would have just
been for this Society but then you have
to ask was that appropriate or correct
like you could go to vote no no I'm
saying you might want to return it
Society I might wanna I might want to
return it guys okay
that sounds interesting
that's what I'm saying I mean
guys one at a time I'm talking one at a
time I'm talking okay if I had to go to
war tomorrow and it was it and it was at
the cost of being being able to vote I
would give up the right to vote easy I
don't know I'm not sure y'all trying to
go on the battlefield I'm not no
Absolutely I'll be on the floor in the
kitchen
absolutely but that's only because
that's a problem which this Society
created in terms of they tied being able
to vote to having to get drafted in the
war the two of those things didn't have
to be connected that's a that's a here
thing that could be it used to be but it
used to be with owning property yeah so
you you couldn't vote unless you owned
property because they wanted it was an
informed populace yeah I mean I'm not
completely 100 familiar with the history
of that but the point I'm trying to make
is that's a sort of
engineered problem if you get what I'm
saying the two of those things didn't
have to be connected but you could go to
any other Society at that time maybe I
don't know okay maybe not specifically
at that time because there was a lot of
stuff going on in the world but any
other age and yes you did have places
where women can vote you as you said
women were in positions of power women
were in positions of you know X Y and Z
but we now live in an age where despite
the flaws of the West we do live in a
place which encourages things like as I
said critical thinking or freedom of to
be freedom of you know X Y and Z it
might be that this current social
Consciousness is going in the correct in
in an incorrect way or in a way that
kind of creates problems but that is a
value which I don't think should be
given up for anything because that
mindset that freedom to you know
actually of thought to be to experience
to be able to you know um
change things up it's what makes you
think that value isn't there just
perceived and allocated differently
how do you mean like in other cultures
yeah I think it's quite I think it's
demonstrating so can I have an example
of what culture specifically you're
talking about that doesn't have those
values I mean because I think it's easy
to say oh not in the west but if we're
not talking about a specific culture
okay I mean let me give you an example
of let's say a I don't know what culture
because because often often I've always
heard sorry I'm sorry go ahead I've
always heard and maybe I'm just
incorrectly informed but I have a friend
who's actually living there at the
moment like let's say a country like
Thailand Thailand okay maybe not the
best example in the world but there you
could go there and you can find women
who are much more let's say traditional
in their but in their um how they are
society and you know my friends has
explained to me oh yeah they're all nice
they're all you know really beautiful
here they're all very
you know kind of more traditionalist in
their views now that's not me saying oh
that's all that Thailand consists of but
he's kind of maybe I'm getting it wrong
but he's given me the impression that
that's kind of how this Society is but
you don't think that women can freely
think you don't think no I was in
Thailand oh no they can't really think I
mean but what I'm talking about is
Thailand's social Consciousness their
society their society there are women
there who are much more traditional and
that's why I'm saying there could be
some places where you can go to get much
more traditional wine but yeah but they
can't freely think no they can that's
what I'm just quoting back what you're
saying I'm saying Thai women can't
freely because I feel like you're kind
of going in circles no no I'm not and
you're saying I'm not saying Thai women
aren't really think I'm just giving you
an example of when I was saying there's
places where you could go right and so
when I said okay what place then you
said Thailand and then I'm still in
Thailand and you said the cost at some
of those places where the girls are more
traditional is that they can't freedom
but I'm sorry
okay yeah I mean okay fire enough if I
got it wrong then maybe I'll
mis-explained myself okay but the point
I'm trying to make is their money much
more from what I've heard traditional in
in in the terms of you know how they
carry themselves in society they're much
more traditionalist they you know tend
to be you know if you know much more say
like homekeeping roles and stuff and I'm
I'm not I've never been to Thailand I'm
just saying what I've been told of there
but that would give me let's say an
example of if someone was like oh I'm
gonna go and get a wife from a foreign
country and I can be like yeah Thailand
would be all right I mean why not you've
got women who are much more
traditionalists but they also have more
sort of like freedom and autonomy over
themselves do you know what I'm saying
so now my second they have the freedom
and antotomy over themselves but so
because the social Consciousness is
different where you know the generally
speaking from what I've heard I might be
mistaken am I mistaken maybe it's not
the best example but from what I've
heard they're much more traditional in
how they do things just as in the what
women do and what men do they are that's
what I've heard so someone might be
mistaken I just I just feel like you
said a lot enough yeah it's going around
because no because because I'm like
nobody no no no let me you've been going
so so I'm saying earlier when I asked
you why wouldn't they want to get a wife
from there you were talking about
there's some issue with the free
thinking right or something so long
maybe that's a little off but something
along the lines of like in a more
traditional culture no there's a lack of
yeah I think I get weather yeah and so I
was trying to explain to you firstly
what might be an example of what I meant
when I say oh you can go to another
country and get yeah you know a more um
let's say traditional
um wife and she's much more than a
traditional robot I was trying to give
an example of somewhere where she can be
traditional whilst having the same value
of things like freedom of thought
freedom to be not in a position where
like you're coerced to be well she was
asking me for the bad coach yeah like I
you a culture that like you thought the
women didn't have the oh I would say
Saudi Arabia Saudi Arabia yeah so you
think for me is an example there's no
like there's a like for example just
what I'm saying but I'm saying you don't
know you're wrong but correctly but I'm
saying you don't know that culture and
so like like a joke a joke I make often
is like Saudi Arabia like the women
didn't have the right to drive for a
while and I'm like well yeah if I could
get driven around all the time do I want
the right to drive I mean right you
could say but but what I'm what I'm
saying is like you you can't know what
the women want in that culture like if
you don't know them you've never told
them you're right so so like the men are
saying where can we find these
traditional wives they're not in the
west so like why wouldn't you encourage
someone to go to where the traditional
lives were I was saying before do you
want to marry someone who's a
traditionalist or they're saying yeah
someone who's confined to a box no no I
think they prefer the traditionalist
that's what I'm saying that's why I was
saying I'm might be mistaken yeah I
would recommend oh go somewhere like
time but that's only your interpretation
and and the other thing well and let's
put data behind this right like in the
in the west where where women are the
most like free thinking they're the
least happy and one way that they
measure this is the women are on more
antidepressants than anywhere else in
the world and the women the least happy
demographic of women is single childless
and make over fifty thousand dollars per
year yeah so it's like so that's true so
so I'm saying like we could judge those
cultures and say maybe they don't have a
choice but maybe women but maybe okay I
need you to let me finish this is my
show so all right so so I'm saying when
you're in those cultures like you don't
know you can't say those women aren't
happy some women it's like you too much
Choice ruins us but you could say it
about everyone it's true the psychology
of choice yeah less happy with your
choices but like another example is body
count a lot of times in non-western
cultures women's body count are lower so
for example if a woman has sex with one
person she's a virgin on her wedding
night she's an 80 chance of being in a
happy marriage in 10 years on the other
hand if she slept with five or more
people which honestly based on the guys
that I talked to on this show they're
praying their girl has five or less
bodies they're like they're like that's
amazing but even but even five or less
that that's a 25 chance of a happy
marriage so it goes from 80 to 25 by
Sleeping with five or more people and so
when when the guys are thinking do I
want a western women who the average age
of first marriage in the UK is 31 how
many bodies is she gonna have by 31
right
so so average age of first marriage in
the U.S is 27 almost 28 so how many how
many bodies is she gonna have by then
like like the this choice and empowering
women doesn't leave us happy
no and so that's why that's why men want
to avoid Western women I mean but you
don't have to agree but I'm saying like
they they survey women yeah they're not
as happy yeah